so red pill manosphere dude dude man so
man is feared dude you've dealt in that
world though you've interviewed a bunch
of these guys no and now it's so it's
like why are you guys so afraid of women
man it's like they're great they love
you it's okay you don't have to be
afraid of them like you don't have to
like dunk on them all the time there's a
lot of great women that are out there I
think I need to see more like married
red pill dudes you know what I mean
because there's like it's very rare that
I see like guys in happy marriages just
dunking on women all the time
that's what I said like I'm not taking
advice from uh you know single dudes on
you know how to be with women straight
up huh I mean like if it's how to get
some [ __ ] sure tell me yeah but if it's
how to like build a life and have
children like yeah if you're trying to
get what you're gonna tell me about
getting married yeah you're not to get
married or they would tell you that
marriage is a bad deal for men or if
you're gonna do get married you're gonna
need a prenup I assume you had this
conversation with what uh fresh and fit
in these guys yeah yeah we had we had
with them I just I don't know I feel
like they operate from a place of fear
man and I don't think that that's
healthy I don't want to teach men to be
afraid